[Musique]
vous vous êtes bénie au lac cet été
l'eau était incroyablement transparente
il y avait des poissons partout et
surtout surtout ça rendait ses
températures caniculaires un peu plus
supportables le même épisode de chaleur
il y a 40 ans ça n'aurait pas été la
même
la plupart des plages étaient interdites
à la baignade
contamination bactériologique et eaux
polluée
de toute façon vous n'auriez pas eu
tellement envie de vous baigner l'eau
aurait été verte
alors que s'est-il passé en 40 ans
comment est-on passé d'un lac décrit
comme un lac à l'agonie au Léman que
nous connaissons aujourd'hui
en fait je m'apprête à vous raconter une
fois n'est pas coutume une belle
histoire en environnement une histoire
où le collectif a su faire basculer les
décisions politiques du côté de la
régénération environnementale
alors petit guide illustré de la
résolution d'une crise environnementale
en 5 chapitres
chapitre 1 plantons le décor nous sommes
au milieu des années 60 le Léman et
littéralement un égout
les eaux côtières sont contaminés au
bactéries fécales
des concentrations en phosphate ont été
multipliées par 4 depuis la fin de la
Seconde Guerre mondiale des phosphates
agitent comme des fertilisants donc les
algues prolifèrent une fois qu'elle
meurt ces algues tombent au fond où
elles sont dégradées par les microbes
pour repérer cette dégradation des
microbes ont besoin d'oxygène donc plus
il y a d'algues à dégradés plus ces
microbes consomment d'oxygène et
certaines zones profond du lac sont
totalement désoxygénées les stocks de
poissons nobles s'effondre
alors face à cette dégradation de
l'environnement on met en place des
mesures on construit ces énormes
piscines luxueuses à 2 mètres du bord
comme on voit à Genève à Lausanne à
Thonon pour essayer de maintenir une
baignade avec une vue sur le lac
pour les poissons on met en place des
pisciculteurs d'État qui ont pour
mission de pêcher des géniteurs de faire
de la reproduction au bassin et de
relâcher les alevins quand ils sont
moins sensibles à la pollution
et puisqu'il y a un demi million de
personnes à l'époque qui dépendent du
Léman pour leur eau potable on augmente
la quantité de traitement chimiques
nécessaires pour potabiliser les eaux
mais toutes ces mesures ne sont que
palliatives elles traitent la
conséquence elle ne traite pas la cause
et la situation s'empire au point que en
1970 le chimiste responsable du service
des eaux de Genève sa larmes du fait que
l'on a atteint le plafond des
traitements chimiques que l'on peut
appliquer sur l'eau du Léman pour la
rendre potable
chapitre 2
de l'indignation à la législation
au début du 20e siècle il n'existait pas
de programme de mesures scientifiques
environnementales sur le lac
les personnes qui ont été témoins de
cette dégradation ce sont ces personnes
qui observent lac tous les jours et qui
vivent du lac donc les pêcheurs et en
fait dès la fin du 19e siècle les
pêcheurs commencent à alarmer sur la
dégradation des eaux du lac il
saisissent le Département fédéral de
l’intérieur mais rien ne se passe ce
n'est vraiment qu'à la fin du de la
Seconde Guerre mondiale que l'appel des
pêcheurs est entendue par des
scientifiques comme René mono Jack et
ces scientifiques non seulement ont
commencé à documenter par des faits
scientifiques des données cette
dégradation du lac mais ils se sont
engagés dans des collectifs ils se sont
engagés en politique et ils se sont
appuyés sur les médias pour faire passer
le message le battage médiatique a été
tel qu'en 1955 a été voté en Suisse la
première loi sur la protection des eaux
il était maintenant un délit de polluer
les autres surfaces et l'État fédéral
avait pour deux voir de protéger les
autres
chapitre 3
de la législation à la mise en action
il ne suffit pas de voter une loi pour
qu'elle soit appliquée
protéger les autres surfaces c'est bien
mais faut-il encore savoir de quoi il
faut les protéger quelle est la cause du
problème et quels sont les mesures à
mettre en place pour restaurer la
qualité de ces eaux alors on a créé la
sipèle la Commission Internationale de
protection des eaux du Léman c'est un
organisme franco-suisse qui regroupe des
administratifs des scientifiques et des
dirigeants politiques des deux côtés de
la frontière
et cette si belle a deux missions la
première c'est d'organiser le suivi
scientifique la collecte de données sur
les eaux du Léman et la seconde c'est de
fournir des recommandations qui
permettent d'atteindre une meilleure
qualité des eaux et la selle en a fait
deux
la première est assez évidente
on rejetait jusque-là nos eaux usées
directement dans le lac avec pas ou peu
de traitement
il fallait donc faire en sorte que tous
les habitants et habitants du bassin du
Rhône soit connecté un système
d'épuration des eaux
on a donc posé trois milliards de francs
suisses sur la table et entre les années
60 et 80 de nombreuses stations
d'épuration ont été construites au bord
du lac mais aussi en amont
la contamination bactériologique
s'est stabilisée et pourtant très peu
d'effets sur les fausses fêtes ces
stations d'épuration ne disposaient pas
ou peu de processus de défaussattation
on relarguait toujours autant de
phosphates dans les eaux du lac alors la
Cipale a émis sa deuxième recommandation
il faut traiter le problème des
phosphates à la source et ces phosphates
venaient des détergents détergents dont
l'utilisation avait explosé à la suite
de la Seconde Guerre mondiale alors que
les ménages s'équipaient de plus en plus
de lave-linge et de lave-vaisselle on va
donc voir ces fabricants de détergents
ont leur explique le problème des
phosphates et on leur dit qu'il faut
qu'ils arrêtent de mettre des phosphates
dans les lessives ce à quoi tous les
industriels répondent mais oui bien sûr
tout de suite on va le faire il y a
aucun problème
pas du tout
pas du tout bien sûr que non fin de
non-recevoir les phosphates sont
présents dans les détergents parce que
il lutte contre la dureté de l'eau il
n'existe pas de substituts possibles au
feu sac et quand bien même ça coûterait
trop cher
et puis les lobbies industriels on
l'oreille de la plupart des dirigeants
et sous raison de s'accro-sainte liberté
de commerce on ne cherche pas à
contraindre les industriels
alors on fait des mesurettes c'est à
dire qu'on édite une ordonnance en 77
qui demande aux industriels des
détergents de bien spécifier sur les
barils la bonne quantité de lessive
qu'il faut utiliser
autant vous dire que la sous-commission
qui a édité cette ordonnance comportait
deux fois plus de représentants des
industries que d'habitude et aucun
représentant de la société civile ni des
associations environnementales
donc évidemment cette mesure n'a eu
aucun impact les phosphates ont continué
d'augmenter au point que à la fin des
années 70 les scientifiques salarmaient
de la dégradation du lac au point de
l'appeler à mort en sursis et en
spécifiant que si rien n'était fait dans
les cinq années suivantes les dommages
seraient irréversibles chapitre 4 le
dénouement
on aurait pu en rester là mais là encore
c'est la force du collectif qui agit ce
sont formés de nouveaux collectifs
notamment l'association de sauvegarde
sur le Léman qui regroupait encore des
scientifiques et des citoyens cette
association s'est mobilisée massivement
pour alerter informer s'impliquer en
politique contribuent à l'élaboration
des lois
résultat en 1986 a été votée la loi
suisse interdisant les phosphates dans
les lessives une première à l'échelle de
l'Europe
cette interdiction de phosphate dans les
lessives a eu des effets bénéfiques
spectaculaires sur l'environnement sans
pour autant créer aucune crise du linge
sale en Suisse
les concentrations en phosphate n'ont
cessé de diminuer de pluie et elles sont
aujourd'hui proches de celles qu'il y
avait dans le lac à la fin de la Seconde
Guerre mondiale les bénéfices sur la
qualité de l'eau sont manifestes les
eaux on voit rarement maintenant dans
les eaux c'est prolifération d'algues
elles sont rarissimes
success story mais attention
cette régénération du lac si elle est
manifeste ne reste que partielle les
problèmes de désoxygénation du fond
persiste en fait certains processus
profonds comme l'avait prédit les
scientifiques ont été altérés de façon
durable en quelque sorte le lac a gardé
une mémoire de cette crise des
phosphates
c'est ce qu'on appelle un point de
bascule
en plus ces problèmes de désoxygénation
sont réencés par la crise climatique
actuelle vous le savez sûrement la
quantité de chaleur accumulée dans le
lac est maintenant de plus en plus élevé
avec le réchauffement du climat et il
devient de plus en plus difficile de
brasser cette masse d'eau en hiver or
c'est se retournement hivernal qui
réapprovisionne le fond du lac en
oxygène
alors il faudra à cause de ces points de
bascule et de se renforcerait
enforcement climatique diminuer les
concentrations au phosphate encore plus
bas que ce qu'elle n'était avant la
crise
et enfin chapitre 5 qui a-t-il à retenir
de cette histoire du Léman et de ses
fausses fêtes en fait moi je vois deux
leçons la première c'est qu'il n'existe
pas de bénéfice net à laisser un
environnement se dégrader il coûte à peu
près deux fois et demi plus cher de
mettre en place les mesures qui
permettent de restaurer un écosystème
que celle qui sont nécessaires à le
protéger en plus quel que soit la
quantité d'argent que vous mettez sur la
table
cette régénération sera au mieux
partielle il existe toujours une dette
environnementale et ça c'est à cause de
ces points de bascule ce sont ces points
de bascule que l'on redoute si on
réchauffe le climat au-delà des 1.5
degrés si on passe ces points de bascule
non seulement on aura encore plus de
difficultés à stabiliser le climat mais
surtout on aura encore plus de
difficultés à le prédire
la deuxième leçon c'est la force du
collectif
passons en revue les acteurs de cette
crise des phosphate dont l'élément on a
des lanceurs d'alerte
on a des commissions qui documentent
scientifiquement les faits et qui
fournissent des recommandations des
solutions à la crise et de l'autre côté
on a des lobbies industriels
réfractaires à ces changements au milieu
les politiques libres d'écouter ou pas
les recommandations et les solutions
ça vous rappelle rien
la différence entre la crise des
phosphates et la crise climatique
actuelle c'est la masse du collectif
dans la crise des phosphates sur
l'aimant je ne vous parle pas d'une mare
je vous parle du plus grand réservoir
d'eau potable d'Europe occidentale dans
la crise des phosphates sur l'aimant
c'est le collectif la force du collectif
qui part deux fois à réussir à faire
édicter et appliquer des lois dans deux
pays différents dans le cas de la crise
climatique c'est cette masse critique
dont on a encore besoin alors je sais
que face à l'ampleur des enjeux et des
forces en présence pour ce qui est du
climat on se sent souvent
individuellement assez impuissant
mais quand ça vous arrive
sortez allez vous promener au bord du
lac et dites-vous que ce que vous avez
sous les yeux
c'est la preuve palpable de la victoire
possible d'un collectif de David contre
Goliath
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]